A pure function always returns the same output for the same input.
It doesn't change anything outside itself.
React is designed around this idea.
Every component should be a pure function of its props and state.
Pure components are predictable.
Given the same inputs, they always render the same JSX.
In pure components have side effects.
They change variables outside their scope, make network calls during render, or modify
the DOM directly.
React renders components twice in development strict mode.
This catches impure components that produce different output on each call.
Here's the rule, don't mutate anything that existed before the render started.
Props, state, and context are read only.
You can create and mutate variables inside the component during render, that's fine.
They didn't exist before the call.
Side effects belong in event handlers, not in render.
User clicks, form submissions, timers, those are the right places.
If no event handler fits, use use effect as a last resort.
It runs after render outside the pure rendering phase.
Pure components unlock two react superpowers, memorization, and concurrent rendering.
Memoization means react can skip re-rendering a component if its inputs haven't changed.
This only works if the component is pure.
Concurrent rendering means react can pause, restart, or abandon renders.
In pure components break this entirely.
The mental model, react components are like math functions, f of x always equals the
same result, no surprises.
Let's recap, components must be pure, same input, same output, no mutations during render.
Side effects go in event handlers or use effect.
That's the react series, one concept at a time from the actual docs.